hello games has released a shipload of
info on what will be included in the day
one update for no man's sky which is you
out on Tuesday first up there was a bit
of housekeeping to take care of as
studio founder jean-marie suggested that
you should delete your save if you
played the game prior to installing the
new patch while the game will continue
to work if you choose not to you'll miss
out on some of the new content included
in the patch Mari has said the service
will be wiped on sunday august seven and
again on monday august eight before the
game launches on tuesday on ps4 and a
few days later on pc as for what's in
the patch well buckle up because we have
a lot to get through hello games are
introducing three new pods players can
follow by making different choices early
in the game and to follow a new path
you'll need to start the game on the
fresh save on top of that they've made
changes to the way terrain generation
works tweaks combat mechanics and
increase the size of the games galaxies
tenfold the exploit which led one player
to finish the game in 30 hours has also
been removed for future patches mari
added that they are working on including
the ability to build bases and own giant
space freighters as well as temporal AAA
and cloud rendering tech which will
enhance the game visually other changes
arriving in the day one update include
more diverse creatures extreme hazardous
planets more variation in atmosphere and
planets more ship diversity deeper
trading mechanics as well as a number of
bouncing and stability alterations to
get all the nitty-gritty details on
precisely what is coming your way in the
no man's sky day one update be sure to
check back to our story on site and stay
tuned to gamespot for all the latest
you